in House of the Dragon episode 3 The
King kills a stag the princess kills a
boar and the prince kills a crab feeder
there's a battle and a party and no one
has fun except for this pug so what
happens and what does it mean this video
has no spoilers Beyond Hot D episode 3.
the episode starts about three years
after the previous episode King viserys
has married Alison Hightower they've had
a baby named aegon and Allison is
pregnant with another child to celebrate
aegon's second birthday they hold a
royal hunt we saw a royal hunt in the
original Game of Thrones show and
throne's Author George Martin said this
was his least favorite scene in the
entire show cause this Hunt is just four
Dudes walking in the woods when George
said that a royal hunt should be a big
event with a hundred dudes and Tents and
dogs and horns so the hunt in Hot D is
much closer to the author's Vision with
tents and dogs and horns they hunt in
the Kingswood which is a forest near
King's Landing where only the king is
allowed to hunt animals last episode
mentioned a poacher who was brought to
justice for the crime of hunting here so
the Hunt is like a big festival with
lots of food and guests viserys wants
everyone to just have fun and celebrate
together but the Lords have political
agendas Hobart Hightower is the Lord of
Old Town and he's the older brother of
Otto Hightower the hand of the king the
high Towers want King viserys to make
Alison hightower's son aegon heir to the
throne instead of rhaenyra who viserys
earlier named as air because if Otto's
grandson becomes the king that could
make the hightowers more powerful
previously it seemed like Otto was
motivated by his own ambition but now we
see Hobart pressuring him and telling
him what to do last episode call us
talked about second Sons how younger
brothers are overshadowed by their older
brother and have to fight for a place in
the world we see that dynamic in Hobart
and Otto as well as in Corliss and
vemond and in viserys and Daemon lots of
brother stuff this episode we meet Jason
Lannister and his twin brother Thailand
Lannister these guys are ancestors of
Cersei Jaime and Tyrion Lannister Jason
is the Lord of casterly rock and
Thailand is now on viserys's Council as
master of ships to replace Corliss the
books say that viserys chose Thailand to
be master of ships because the
Lannisters supported viserys back at the
Harren Hall Council Jason and Thailand
are both played by actor Jefferson Hall
who once played sir Hugh in Game of
Thrones season one you might not
remember Sir Hugh cause he didn't last
very long Lord Lionel strong brings his
sons Laris and Harwin Harwin is said to
be the strongest Knight in the realm and
has the nickname break bones larus is
called the clubfoot because he has a
deformed foot and has trouble walking so
instead of joining the hunt larus sits
with the ladies and listens quietly the
official website says larus is ingenious
but underestimated the name Laris sounds
like Varys and Varys is also a man who
listens and knows the value of
information princess rhaenyra reads in
the godswood making a Minstrel play the
same song over and over like an iPod on
repeat the mineral's name is Samwell
which might be a reference to Casablanca
when a musician called Sam has to keep
playing the same song rhaenyra's song
and Rainier's book are about nymeria the
ancient Eastern princess who sailed
across the sea to escape the dragonlords
like nymeria rhaenyra dreams of freedom
and Escape in episode 1 we saw rhaenyra
and Alison here when they were best
friends but now rhaenyra is cold and
distant to Alison she still feels angry
and betrayed that her friend suddenly
became her stepmom and her Queen
rhaenyra tells the minstrel to stay but
Alison tells him to leave and the
minstrel obeys Alison not rhaenyra cause
Queen Alison now outranks princess
rhaenyra rhaenyra hates that she's been
replaced by Alison so she refuses
Alison's attempts to reconnect on the
road Allison says that her baby's birth
was quick and easy and then there's an
awkward pause because everyone's
reminded of rhaenyra's mum Emma who died
in childbirth in episode 1. at the
hunting camp everyone cheers for baby
aegon aegon's grand Uncle Hobart Tower
calls aegon second of his name and his
grace which is what you would say if
aegon was King even though officially
rhaenyra is heir to the throne many
lords want a male ruler not a woman so
while everyone cheers aegon rhaenyora
sits alone and ignored we hear that lady
Johanna Swann was abducted in the
stepstones because the stepstones are
currently occupied by the triarchy the
Eastern Alliance led by the crab feeder
the books say that the triaki impose
heavy taxes on ships passing through the
stepstone's trade routes and they don't
just take money the triarchy kidnap
people and sell them into sex slavery in
the city of lease Johanna Swann was the
15 year old niece of a lord and after
being kidnapped she became a famous
courtesan in lease and eventually was
the ruler of the city known as the Black
Swan we meet Kiera Lannister the mother
of Jason and Thailand and we meet lady
Jocelyn of house redwine an ancestor of
the queen of thorns Jocelyn criticizes
King viserys so rhaenyra insults Jocelyn
which is funny but it's probably not
smart if rhaenyra Wants to Rule she
needs allies and insulting powerful
people is not gonna help despite being
heir to the throne rhaenyra isn't acting
like a politician she's more like a
grumpy teenager while Alison acts more
diplomatically she behaves like a queen
Jason Lannister tries to flirt with
rhaenyra because rhaenyra is now of an
age to be married and as a royal
princess everyone wants her Jason tries
to impress Rainier by bragging about his
wealth the Lannisters are the second
richest family in the realm after the
valerians Jason says that he's got a
really big penis I mean a really big
Castle castley Rock is taller than the
Hightower and taller than the wall in
the books it's like a mountain with
tunnels and rooms carved all through it
though when we saw castly Rock in Game
of Thrones it was not as impressive
Jason says that he could build a dragon
pit so if rhaenyra marries him she could
keep dragons at casterly Rock and this
is not the first time that Lannisters
have tried to get dragons the old King
jiharis had a sister called Rayna Rayna
and her Dragon dream fire stayed with
the Lannisters for a while and the
Lannisters tried to convince Rayna to
give the Lannister's dragon eggs or to
marry a Lannister so that their children
could have dragons because with Dragon
Riders of their own the Lannisters could
become as powerful as the targaryens
many of the Great houses were Kings
before the targaryens took over so all
the proud Lords are envious of Targaryen
Dragon power
rhaenyra is angry that viserys wants to
marry her off she doesn't want to be
sent away to live with some husband and
she doesn't want viserys to disinherit
her and give the throne to aegon instead
viserys handles his unhappy Daughter by
shouting at her in a public political
event which is a terrible idea so
rhaenyra rides away like princess
nymeria fleeing the dragonlords
Otto says there's been a sighting of a
white heart a deer with a rare pale
color in Westeros and in real mythology
a white heart is seen as a rare blessing
from the gods and a symbol of royalty if
they catch this white heart on baby
aegon's birthday it could be seen as a
sign that aegon should be the heir to
the throne
Otto admits that he doesn't normally
believe in signs and portents but he
will pretend to believe any old crap if
it means that his grandson becomes king
Jason Lannister gives viserys a fancy
spear to honor aegon gifts are a way to
try to win political favors from Kings
Jason mentions the golden Gallery which
is a place in casterly rock with gilded
ornaments and walls it sounds like the
Palace of Versailles or someplace Jason
says that he expects aegon to become
Heir instead of rhaenyra so viserys
drunkenly [ __ ] talks and teases the
Lannister to put him in his place like
how King Robert drunkenly made fun of
Lancel Lannister in Game of Thrones king
Robert and King viserys are both
charismatic characters who really suck
at being King and use alcohol to cope
while terrible conflicts Brew around
them
Otto tells viserys that he should marry
rhaenyra to aegon viserys laughs at the
absurdity of marrying his daughter to
her two-year-old half-brother but the
age gap between rhaenyra and aegon is
less than the gap between viserys and
his wife Alison and the targaryens have
a long tradition of marrying their
siblings viserys's parents were siblings
and his grandparents were siblings so
since rhaenyra and aegon are only
half-siblings this would be one of the
less incestuous Targaryen Royal
marriages marrying a Targaryen would
prevent other families from potentially
getting dragons and Arena aegon marriage
could prevent any potential conflict
between the two for the throne but
viserys is sick of the [ __ ]
politicking and returns to his wine the
king is surrounded by people but is very
alone and stressed viserys is now
missing two fingers because his finger
was cut on the throne in episode 1 and
was rotting in episode 2. now the
infected fingers have been amputated the
king is literally falling apart
disintegrating under the weight of his
crown
Lionel strong says that viserys is not
the first Targaryen King to have trouble
with his daughter the previous King
jahiris had constant problems with his
daughters Alyssa was a wild tomboy
daiella was a scaredy cat Sarah ran off
to a brothel and visero was a narcissist
Lionel says that rebellious Targaryen
girls are tradition of course if every
generation of Targaryen women struggle
against the political system that might
be a sign that it's the system that's
the problem not the women but they
discuss a husband for rheniera and
viserys expects Lionel to say that
rhaenyra should marry his son Harwin but
it turns out that Lionel is the one guy
who doesn't recommend his own family's
interests Lionel says that rhaenyra
should marry Lenor valerion lanor is the
son of Corliss valerion and rhaenys
Targaryen he's the heir to the rich
house valerion marrying lanor had
finally fix the tension between the
targaryens and Valarie pounds after
viserys rejected Lena valerion and
rhaenix was rejected at the harrenhall
council viserys seems to appreciate that
Lionel gives unbiased advice but he also
is too wasted to walk in a straight line
so rhaenyra runs off into the woods and
she is followed by her sworn protector
Kristen Cole rhaenyra and Kristen have
become close over the last few years
rhaenyra complains about being married
off about not having a choice and being
powerless but Kristen reminds her that
she's a princess and her life is way
better than most people's lives in this
Medieval World and rhaenyra is not
powerless by choosing Kristen for the
kingsguard rhaenyra changed Kristen's
life for the better as a lower class
person Kristen can give rhaenyra the
perspective of someone less privileged
than her
rhaenyra insists on hanging in the woods
instead of returning to camp and they
get attacked by a boar Kristen wounds
the animal and then rhaenyra brutally
stabs it to death unleashing her
emotions through violence rhaenyra is
full of suppressed anger at her father
and pain from Alison's betrayal so she
lets it all out on this animal rhaenyra
said earlier that dying boars squeal
like children and then the child aegon
made a squealing sound so now when
rhaenyra kills this squealing boar maybe
she's imagining stabbing aegon the baby
that threatens to replace her as Heir
viserys tells Alison about his dreams
many targaryens have prophetic dreams of
the future like Danish Targaryen dreamed
about the Doom of valyria before it
happened and that's how the targaryens
escaped the doom and came to Westeros
Danish wrote a book of her Visions
called signs and portents which is the
same phrase that Otto uses to describe
the white heart we know that viserys
once dreamed that he would have a son
and that son would be king but when Emma
and her son died viserys lost faith in
this dream he gave up on having a son
and that's why he named rhaenyra as Heir
instead but now that viserys finally has
a son aegon he's doubting himself again
maybe his dream of a son was right after
all and aegon should be there not
rhaenyra the white heart is part of his
doubt if they find the white heart on
aegon's birthday that sign might
convince viserys that aegon should be
the heir so viserys is full of doubt and
guilt and grief which is similar to
other Targaryen dreamers in the Hedge
Knight Novella daeron Targaryen feels
tortured by his dreams and he uses
alcohol to try to escape them into a
dream dreamless sleep
daeron's brother aemon says that dreams
killed his brothers everyone
Alison who looks concerned that her
husband and King is drunkenly rambling
about using dreams to decide the future
of the realm and of her son in the
morning they find a deer but it's not
the white heart it's just a normal Brown
Deer so viserys feels relieved there was
no special Omen on aegon's birthday so
maybe viserys made the right choice
after all and rhaenyra should be the
heir viserys is expected to kill this
deer even though he didn't hunt it down
himself and he doesn't really want to
kill it this moment is similar to how
viserys had his wife Emma killed she
also was held down and helpless
sacrificed reluctantly by viserys this
is the job of a king to sacrifice people
for the good of the realm soldiers in
battle women in childbirth but viserys's
compassion makes him reluctant to make
these sacrifices and that's why it's
hard for him to be King viserys fails to
kill the deer cleanly and has to stab it
twice which is another bad Omen it's
like when Theon struggles to kill
Roderick in Game of Thrones this
execution is ugly and farcical and makes
everyone look bad the deer can also
represent King viserys himself because
the deer is a strong Regal animal but
it's also constrained struggling pulled
in different directions by these men
just as viserys is pulled in different
directions by his Lords and their
politics in Game of Thrones episode 1 a
dead stag foreshadows the death of King
Robert who was killed by a boar so this
dead stag could be foreshadowing for
viserys meanwhile rhaenyra is covered in
the blood of her violence her killing
was not some fake ceremonial Slaughter
it was real hot-blooded violence to
defend herself from an attack and as she
looks over the Kingswood the white heart
appears to her just walks right up like
some mystical sign from the gods that
rhaenyra should be the heir Kristen
draws his sword but rhaenyra tells him
not to kill the heart this shows that
rhaenyra can be merciful and peaceful in
contrast to her killing of the boar not
killing the white heart also fits with
the animal's mythology in the Game of
Thrones books Sansa thinks that in the
stories Knights never harm white Hearts
so rhaenyra plays the role of the noble
heroes in the stories but if rhaenyra
did Kill the white heart and showed
everyone back at camp that might have
convinced people to support her as Heir
her choice not to kill the heart could
represent rhaenyra choosing not to go
for the throne so just like all the
dreams and prophecies this mystical sign
is ambiguous it's up to the characters
and the viewers to decide decide what
this sign means rhaenyra brings the boar
back to Camp so she still gets to prove
herself to everyone Jason Lannister is
grossed out by the blood but Harwin
strong is visibly into it
back at the red cape Otto speaks with
his daughter Allison they're quite
formal and distant with each other
Otto calls Alison Your Grace which
suggests that Otto sees Alison Moore as
a political figure than as his daughter
Otto says that her son aegon will
inherit the throne because he's male
Alison insists that rhaenyra is the heir
But Otto tells her to convince viserys
to name aegon as the new Heir Alison
speaks with viserys and tells him that
rhaenyra will marry if she thinks it's
her choice to marry which sounds a
little manipulative but it also shows
that Alison understands rhaenyra's
feelings and wants her to be happy
Allison learns that the war in the
stepstones is going badly viserys
doesn't want to help Daemon and call us
because Daemon and Corliss started this
war against viserys's wishes and he
doesn't want to look weak but Alison
says that viserys should do what's best
for the realm regardless of his personal
feelings which is what a king should do
and Alison doesn't bring up making aegon
air like Otto told her to so Alison
isn't just going along with her father's
plots she advocates for the greater good
instead maybe Alison is a good Queen
this is the first episode where we don't
see Alison picking at her fingernails
she has now become more confident but
her exact goals and plans are not yet
clear viserys listens to Alison and
sends reinforcements to help Daemon and
the valerians viserys and rhaenyra argue
some more about rhaenyra getting married
viserys admits that he married Alison
out of selfish desire not political
Advantage so he says he'll let rhaenyra
choose who she wants to marry and
viserys swears that he won't replace
rhaenyra as Heir so viserys affirms his
support for rhaenyra privately but many
of the Lords don't know that and still
see aegon as the here and if rhaenyra
marries for desire instead of a
political Advantage she might not have
the support she needs to claim the
throne when viserys dies while the
royalty uh plotting and feasting on the
stepstones men are fighting for their
lives the valerians and Prince Daemon
are at war against the triarchy led by
the crab feeder and the war is going
badly for the westerosi we see Daemon
attacking the triarchy with these Dragon
caraxis but the triaki learned to avoid
the Dragons by hiding in caves these
Guerrilla tactics are similar to how the
dornish successfully resisted aegon's
dragons we see daemon's dragons stomp on
one of his own men which shows that
Daemon doesn't really care who he kills
and shows that dragons are not precise
weapons when dragons go to war there's
collateral damage and ordinary people
get killed Daemon gets shot with an
arrow and and his Dragon caraxis cries
out as though in pain the books say that
there's a mysterious bond between dragon
and Dragon Rider like some psychic
connection that lets dragons feel what
their Riders feel in the books the
Starks and their direwolves have a
similar connection so Daemon and
karaxi's cause some Havoc but they fail
to find the crab feeder the valerions
are led by Lord Corliss valerion we also
meet corliss's younger brother vemond
valerion a commander in their Navy vemon
seems to have a combative relationship
with his brother like viserys and Daemon
and Hobart and Otto lanor valerion is
the son of Corliss and rhaenys he seems
to have had a big growth spurt since we
saw him in episode 1. and this guy is
Sir Joffrey lawnmuth he's called the
Knight of kisses because the heraldry of
house lawnmith has red lips on it the
valerions are outnumbered they're
running out of food and they fear
they'll soon be eaten by crabs but then
Daemon finds out that his brother
viserys sent reinforcements to help them
which you would think would be good news
but Daemon gets so angry that he beats
up the messenger cause as viserys said
Daemon would rather die than accept help
from his big brother Daemon is here to
prove himself to show that he can win by
his own strength so before viserys's
reinforcements arrive Daemon leads a
suicidally dangerous attack the plan is
for Daemon to lure the crab feeder out
of his caves so Daemon goes alone and he
pretends to surrender by waving a white
flag only to betray the triarchy and
attack them anyway it's like in Game of
Thrones when Ramsay gets Theon to use a
peace Banner to get some ironborn to
surrender but then Ramsay betrays the
ironborn and kills them any way this is
another example of Daemon breaking rules
to get what he wants Daemon
single-handedly kills like a dozen dudes
Dodges arrows does a barrel roll and
somehow doesn't die and just when he
seems doomed he's saved by Lenor
valerion on his Dragon sea smoke
so they didn't mention it till now but
Lenor has a dragon because Lenor has
Targaryen Dragon Blood through his
mother rhaenys Targaryen rhaenys herself
also has a dragon called melis the Red
Queen the other Dragon Riders currently
are rhaenyra with the yellow dragon
Cyrax and Daemon with the red dragon
karaxis there are also a bunch of other
dragons around that currently don't have
Riders like Verma Thor the bronze Fury
which was the dragon of the Old King
jiharis Silverwing was the dragon of
jeharis's wife alisane dreamfire was
Reina targaryen's dragon and vegar is on
the East Coast somewhere plus there are
probably a bunch more hatchlings and
eggs on Dragonstone we'll see many more
dragons later in this story sea smoke is
a silvery gray dragon and he's a young
dragon fast and Nimble in Flight he and
Lenor burn the triarchy from the sky
while the valerian attack on the ground
led by Lord Corliss and by vemond Daemon
goes after the crab feeder and finally
kills the crab in the book Daemon cuts
off the crab feeder's head but in the
show he butchers him off screen Daemon
gets covered in the crab feeder's blood
which might be a bad idea because
according to behind the scenes info the
crab feeder had grayscale a disease that
can be highly contagious and deadly so
is Daemon gonna get infected and turn
into a stone man in the Game of Thrones
show grayscale can be cured Jorah
Mormont and Shireen Baratheon are both
cured of grayscale but in the books it's
different the books say that there are
different forms of grayscale the Swift
gray plague is deadly but there's a
different form of the disease that
affects children it gives them Stoney
gray skin but it doesn't kill and it's
not contagious so maybe crab feeder had
a form of grayscale that isn't
contagious so Daemon is safe there's
also an idea in the books that
targaryens are immune to diseases that
the blood of the dragon has a purifying
fire that saves targaryens from getting
sick Daenerys Targaryen believes this
and she never gets sick even when she
visits disease victims in the books but
some other targaryens do die of disease
King daeron Targaryen II and his
grandkids die of a plague and maegel
Targaryen dies of grayscale so not all
targaryens are immune to disease but
maybe some are there are hints that it's
only targaryens who have dragons who
don't get sick King daeron and Miguel
don't have dragons but Daenerys and
Daemon do so maybe Daemon is immune to
disease that said crab feeder's
grayscale is not in the books it's never
actually he mentioned in this show and
it sounds like the showrun has just
added it to make the crab feeder look
scary the point is that daemon's
Reckless violence wins him Victory and
his blood-sirked killing is similar to
rhaenyra's violence with the boar while
King viserys awkwardly Slaughters a
defenseless deer rhaenyra and Daemon win
real victories against Real enemies the
showrunners say that these characters
are reborn finding new strength and
purpose forged Stronger by Fire and
Blood
if you want to know more about when the
Lannisters tried to get dragons from
Rayna Targaryen or about King jahiris's
rebellious daughters the full story is
told in Fire and Blood you can get Fire
and Blood On audiobook for free right
now at audible.com ASX sign up for a
Premium Plus trial membership and you
can get an audiobook to keep even if you
cancel the trial you can get any Game of
Thrones book or Lord of the Rings or
Dune membership also includes unlimited
access to thousands of audiobooks and
shows in the audible plus catalog sign
up at audible.com ASX or text ASX to
500-500 thanks for watching please like
And subscribe you might also like to
sign up to the altshift X audio feed
where you can get all of these videos as
podcast episodes so you can listen on
Spotify or your podcast app thank you to
the patrons including Dr falter Broski
bakes Zoe cerullo Kyo Alves Kyle and
Rogue Prince cheers